one of the biggest surprises from e3
this year was Mario plus rabbit's
kingdom battle not that it existed mind
you we knew that before thanks to a
bunch of late what was surprising was
the reveal that it was an ex-con like
strategy game for everything Mario and
Rabbids make sure you're subscribed and
you can head the game sport for
everything you need to know about your
Nintendo switch you certainly can but
for now we've had a bit of time with the
Ubisoft innovation of the Mushroom
Kingdom and here's five things we think
you should know
[Music]
mário plus Rabbids is not XCOM light
it's hardcore turn-based strategy let's
get this one out of the way early yes
Mario Puss Roberts plays a lot like XCOM
anyone who's familiar with for axises
tactical turn-based alien invasion
series will feel right at home when they
pick up the switch controller the
parallels are something the devs
anticipated too which led them to
increase the game's difficulty like XCOM
you have to think carefully about team
makeup and how you want to engage
because the titular battles for the
kingdom are not messing around in Mario
Plus Rapids team is made up of three
characters Mario is mandatory and so is
at least one rabbit the third slot can
be filled with whomever you choose be it
rapid Yoshi and his machine gun or
Princess Peach for her area of effect
healing during our preview session we
saw more than one fellow player throw
their hands up in exasperation as they
failed their third try at a particularly
tricky bite you'll need to take cover
plan your movements and rely on team
abilities such as the team jump which
allows a member of your team to be
catapulted across the map if you are to
succeed unlike XCOM members of your team
can attack move and use an ability in
any order without ending your turn and
you won't have to contend with permitir
your weapon choices are varied and
change your combat style you may
remember when Ubisoft 1e3 2017 by having
CEO Yves Guillermo and Mario creator
Shigeru Miyamoto pose back-to-back while
holding replica Mario Plus rabbits
blasters on stage at their conference
turns out those blasters are just the
tip of the iceberg when it comes to
banishing those pesky rabbits from the
Mushroom Kingdom
each character can opt to use either
their primary or secondary weapon during
their turn that could include Mario's
blaster and mallet combo or Luigi's
long-range vacuum blaster and robotic
sentry bomb each of these weapons have
different attack and cool-down stats as
well as status effects that you should
take into account before running
headlong into battle for instance
weapons with a honey status effect have
a chance to hold enemies in place for a
turn while the ink status will cancel an
enemy's attacks the bounce effect proved
to be the most valuable but be warned it
can be both a blessing and a curse while
sometimes a successful bounce shot will
send a particularly strong rabbit
bouncing erratically out of bounds for
extra damage there's also a chance that
it will bounce your enemies into a more
advantageous position for that
or your allies into danger similarly
weapons with an area of effects such as
robotic sentry bombs and throwable
explosives have a chance of damaging
your teammates on more than one occasion
my ill-planned sentry robots ant Mario
flying out of bounds to his doom
planning your team makeup and battle
strategy is essential so you've got a
handful of characters with only three
slots to fill a variety of weapons to
choose from and a veritable crap ton of
abilities to assign to whomever you
choose to fill out your party your next
step is making all those work together
to complement one another just like you
would in any other team based strategy
game you can chain together useful
abilities from one character to the next
like super jumps tackles and AoE buffs
to help yourself get a big boost on the
battleground so making sure your team
makeup allows that is essential figure
out whether you're going for speed mass
destruction or staying well out of the
enemy's line of sight you'll then want
to factor in the health of each of your
prospective teammates there are special
skills which could include anything from
healing to Mario and rabbits version of
X comms overwatch which allows your
character to take a shot at a moving
enemy outside of your turn
depending on how you balance your team
you could have a fairly easy time or a
very very hard one also if you elect to
put rabbit peach and her healing skill
in your party try not to have her die
early it does not make for a good time
tactical view is super super useful your
first step is to factor in the kind of
mission you're playing some victory
conditions require you to defeat all the
nasty rabbits on the battlefield while
others just call for you to reach a
certain area of the map with at least
one of your trio still standing it's
trickier than it sounds when you deal
with enemies who can teleport you or
blast you to smithereens if you leave a
teammate out in the open at the
beginning of each encounter you'll have
the opportunity to access the tactical
view this is a super handy feature where
you can view the entire battleground and
find the best route to the end goal by
figuring out where the best cover is
where your foes are spawning and other
environmental factors that might deter
your progress like warp pipes which let
faraway enemies run all the way up to
you in one turn or threatening boozhoo
teleport you all over the damn map when
you were this far from the end zone as
ghosts later in the engagement you'll
more than likely need to contend with
cover that's been demolished
you were standing behind it to the
tactical view also lets you scan foes so
you can discover their attack and
defense attributes as well as their
abilities which should help you decide
on the best way to defeat them my best
advice for getting by in these battles
is to take your time there is no time
limit so your route through any given
map will be as successful as the choices
you make from turn-to-turn because of
all the different abilities there are
also lots of different ways to succeed
and trying out new options and combos
it's pretty fun
co-op is really fun and also incredibly
difficult
unfortunately mario + rabbits doesn't
feature a co-op campaign but it does
have a great local co-op mode instead of
a three character team from the main
game you and your partner will get a two
character team H if you want Princess
Peach to fight alongside her rabid
superfan you can once you've decided on
who's who you can choose the map and
game type and get stuck into
strategizing just like in the campaign
turns can be made in any order and teams
can swap out depending on strategy it's
also a really great way to lose friends
if you're the competitive sort and
aren't 100% agreed on how you're going
to take on your foes from the get-go
overall I've really enjoyed Mario Plus
Rapids Kingston battle I think if you go
in expecting regular Mario antics you're
gonna be really confused and possibly
disappointed but as someone who grew up
playing strategy games I really loved my
time with this one and I really do mean
my time I took a horrific Lea long time
deciding who I wanted to fight with and
how a long time Rabbids found an
apologist I can't wait to see how this
one fares when it's released on August
29 stay tuned the game support for
everything else Mario in Robertson
thanks so much for watching
[Music]